what's going on everybody welcome to
part six of the neural networks from
scratch video series
in this video what we're going to be
talking about and covering is the
softmax activation function which is
specifically used for the output layer
on our classification style neural
network
models before we get into that a quick
update the
uh neural networks from scratch book is
now fully released uh we have a hard
cover which you see here as well as a
softcover
also the ebook now has a pdf download
all books give you access to that pdf
and ebook
and we still also have the google docs
so you can still
highlight and ask questions in line with
the text and all that
if you're interested in any version of
the book you can get it at nnfs.io
i am going to be coding everything from
the book so you should be able to watch
the videos read the book and kind of
cross back and forth with very little
uh effort that way if maybe you've coded
something from the video and then you're
still maybe a little confused you want
to get a refresher you could go
in theory back to the book for example
and kind of go through the exact same
code
just in written form or vice versa and
so on so anyway
we're going to be starting off here with
the softmax activation function
and the first question that i'm sure
many people will have
is why another activation function why
don't we just continue to use something
like the rectified linear activation
function
so um i think to start us off uh i would
say let's just i'm going to start with a
fresh script here
just for illustration purposes and then
once we actually code the code that we
intend to can
you know continue with our essentially
we're building a framework here so
um for that code we'll go back to the
code that we've been building um but for
now we're just gonna start fresh so
let's just say you've got some layer
outputs
and the values can be anything we're
just going to make them up but i am
going to use the values from the book
4.8 1.21 2.385
so imagine these are your output values
what do we do with that so if we're only
predicting it's pretty simple
you do you just you would say the
prediction is whichever one of these
values
is the is the largest so in this case it
would be index zero
so let's assume index zero is indeed the
intended target
um awesome you got your prediction right
but
what we're trying to learn how to do is
actually train neural networks as well
so
with you don't have to think about this
if all you're doing is predicting but
someone had to think about it at some
point to train this model
so if you want to train a model the you
know there's a whole
bunch that goes on that we will get to
and that will take up many videos and
and many
uh hours of your time to figure out and
learn how this works
but um at this point
the first step in training a model is
to determine how wrong
is this model right because accuracy is
not a good indication of that so for
example
uh if we change some of these values
maybe 4.7 4.79 and 4.25 i don't know
which one of which one of these is more
correct
well i think probably most people would
agree
this first one is more correct because
relatively
this neuron zero here is
relatively larger than the other neurons
um in this list whereas here they're
actually a lot closer
accuracy wise they're identical um
so so in order to measure how wrong
something is where we
first the first order of business is to
compare them relatively to other neurons
but
the problem with this is like the
rectified linear activation function for
example
is exclusive it's per neuron they're not
really connected in any way so there is
no relative comparison that you could
really fairly make the next problem
is these are unbounded so the relative
closeness can vary
and we just we don't really have a good
solid way of determining
um how wrong is this in any formal
uh uniform way per sample that comes
through
so um this is the problem and this is
why we need
some new activation function which in
this case we're going to be using the
softmax activation function
to help us solve now why softmax
well we need to kind of again kind of
consider what's our what's our end
objective here
so zooming out to a full model for the
moment
uh what what what actually do we want to
happen so let's say we've got some image
data we're going to pass that through
the neural network
and then we get the output values now
what do we want those values to be
so ideally these values would be a
probability distribution
this gives us the ability for well it
gives us a few things first of all
this means everything will be uniform
from sample to sample
also from neuron to neuron things will
be normalized
and we can actually calculate rightness
and wrongness
so to speak so in this case the the
correct classification
if everything was perfect uh the the
correct classification would be a 1.0
and the all the other neurons would read
out 0.0 right
so so now we can actually begin to to to
measure
how right or how wrong are we so we know
this is where we want to get
and the question is how do we actually
get to that point
so one immediate idea here might be well
all you need to really do
is normalize the values and create that
distribution by
taking each neuron's value and divide
that value by the
total value of all the neurons in that
layer and then you're done
right so let's say you just use a
probability distribution and you keep
old faithful
rectified linear activation function the
problem here
is if any of those values in the output
layer is a
negative the rectified linear activation
function is going to
clip it and it's just going to be a zero
and then when we go to create a
probability distribution from that
it will always be zero whether it was a
negative twenty
or negative nine thousand and then the
other problem is what if all of the
values are in the negatives uh there
would be it would be impossible to learn
from here
and and again we haven't quite yet
reached back propagation
but learning from clipped values um
quote-unquote how wrong or how right is
something
is very difficult because there is no
meaning once you've clipped you've lost
all meaning was it a negative 20 before
it got clipped or was it a negative 1
million
we don't know so then you might suggest
let's just use
a linear activation function let's
basically do nothing
the problem is uh you're still going to
need to figure out what the heck do you
do with these negative values
so you might throw your hands up at this
point be like let's just use absolute
values
or let's square the output then we'll
just solve this whole
negative problem altogether the problem
with this
is after you have these values you need
to be able to back propagate you need to
be able to have an
optimizer intelligently optimize
your variables well if you have a
negative nine that got absolute value to
a nine
that's a big difference than a nine
right um so the variables that you would
need to tweak and the directions that
you would need to tweak these variables
to get those changes that you want
would vary so so we can't just
lose the meaning a negative 9 is not the
same as a positive
9. so what the heck do we do
enter exponentiation so the exponential
function is
y or your output is equal to e or
euler's number
raised to the power of x which is your
input
euler's number is approximately 2.71828
and so on
and exponentiation is the act of
applying the exponential function
to some value so what this does for us
is it solves our negatives issue by
making sure
no negative or really no value can be
negative
at the output of the exponential
function and
it does this while not tossing away the
value or the meaning of that negativity
it's still on
a scale let's say so the exponentiation
of 1.1
is 3 or 3 in some change the
exponentiation of negative
1.1 is 0.3329 or so
so this is more than just using absolute
values or squaring the value for example
now also in theory you don't have to use
euler's number here and you would still
solve all your problems
up to this point but euler's number is
actually going to be coming in handy
later on we'll be sure to reference that
when we get there but this is how we're
solving
those this problem of negativity all
right getting back to our code let's
code the
raw python implementation for
exponentiation so to do this we're just
going to keep the original layer outputs
and first we need a definition for e the
constant euler's number and that is 2.7
i hope i got that right also if you are
in python you can always
import math and then rather than hard
coding
euler's number that way you could say e
equals math.e
and that would be the same thing but if
they are following along in some other
language and you don't have that kind of
math library that just gives you the
number you could just hard code it in
that way
so uh once we have that number we want
to exponentiate
all each of these values so doing that
is really basic python here so we're
going to say
x values we're going to make that an
empty list
and then we're just going to iterate
over layer outputs so for output in
layer outputs we're gonna x values dot
append
um e to the power actually it's capital
e
to the power of uh whatever that output
is
and then when we're all done we can
print x
values let's go ahead and run that and
we have our
exponentiated values at this point
checking the book to make sure it is
identical
and it looks like it is okay great so
that's exponentiation
really not much to it at that point so
the next step once we've exponentiated
these values
is to normalize the values so what do we
mean by
normalize the values so in our case it's
going to be
a single output neuron's value divided
by the sum of all of the other
output neurons in that output layer and
this
gives us the probability distribution
that we that we want
but we still want to exponentiate before
this point because again we need to get
rid of
all of these negative values but we do
not want to lose the meaning
of the negative value so we're
exponentiating to
convert negatives to positives without
actually losing the meaning of a
negative value
so continuing along in our raw python
implementation here
let's go ahead and code in normalization
so again normalization occurs
after we've done exponentiation which
will rid us of these pesky negative
values
so to do the normalization again it's a
single value divided by
the total of all the values so we've got
exponential values so what we're going
to say
is norm base equals the sum of those
exponential values and then we're going
to say norm
of value so yeah there's an empty list
and then we are going to iterate over so
we're going to say four value
in x values we're going to do
norm norm values dot append
and it's just going to be that value
divided by
the norm base and
this will give us the normalized value
so we can
print norm values and then
also this should add up it should add up
to one or very very close to one
so print the sum
of norm values
we'll run that and what we get is here
is our probability distribution so this
first
this first kind of list here this is our
exponentiated values then this is our
normalized exponentiated values
and then this just sums it up and shows
that it does indeed add up to
basically one those values should be
pretty
close to what's in the book is it
actually isn't exactly
um but this isn't using numpy so the
values should line up i think when we're
using numpy
um i'll we'll confirm that when we get
there um but
so the nfs first of all we're not even
initializing the nnfs package
but that is part of what the init
package is doing but here
interestingly enough even raw python
seems to vary from machine to machine
anyways uh it should be very close to
those values and since we're not
actually training a model or anything
it's i don't think it actually matters
at this stage so um
i mean they're close but it's like as
you get to some of these ladder decimals
that's where it's differing
so this that was the uh that's the raw
python implementation and again if
you're
coming from some other language you
would need to implement this in your
language
but now the next thing that we're going
to do is convert this to numpy
so uh so what we're going to do is take
i guess in our code we probably are
retaining e
but we can keep math.e there uh outputs
there we're gonna go ahead and
import uh numpy as
np and rather than
uh doing really all of this
we delete and x values just becomes np
dot x and what are we exponential
what are we applying this exponential
function to layer outputs
so by default typically numpy functions
what they're going to do
is uh first they will they will just by
default impact every value
um and if you want it to be a little
more in a little bit more specific way
you can become more specific and we'll
actually be showing that very shortly
but by default if you just do this it's
going to apply this to each value
in total so that's a quicker way to get
our exponential values
and then for the normalization values
all we
need to do at this point is we're just
going to say
norm underscore values is equal to the
x x values divided by the mp.sum
of the x values so let's go ahead and
run that real quick and then we see that
we do indeed
still get the same value or same ish
values
and this time it actually does line up
with what's in the book but if you
wanted to be super
particular i would imagine we would
import nnf oops
nnfs and nnfs.init
these values actually do line up with
what is in the book but let's just run
that one more time
and so if you did have any variants
there hopefully that would change it
um so okay so that lines up exactly and
as you can see it's a little shorter
code
i think it's a little more legible
but yeah so that is our
our exponentiation and then our
normalization so to sum up
everything up to this point for our
coding of the softmax activation
function
we have input right which is actually
going to be the output layer of data
that we're going to input into
this this activation function we
exponentiate
those those input values so each one
uniquely gets exponentiated
then we normalize and then that becomes
our
output
so the combination of this
exponentiation and
normalization is what makes up the soft
max
activation function the formula for
which is
this and hopefully this formula is
actually pretty simple to understand at
this point since you've already seen the
code that goes into it
and it's not really complicated in any
way
okay so at this point we know everything
that goes into the softmax activation
function and now it is just a
function of actually applying and
implementing this
in such a way that makes sense for our
actual neural network
applications so the main issue that we
have at this stage
is we are currently working with a
single kind of vector here
of a layer's outputs when really we're
not going to have a single layer of
outputs we're actually
or we're not going to have a single
output from
a layer we're going to have a batch of
these outputs because we're going to
have a batch of inputs
and that's going to produce a batch of
outputs
so the next thing we want to do is
convert this
uh and really all this to work
as a batch so to do that uh first let's
let's make this an actual batch
and again i am going to use the same
values that we have
in the book so let me
paste and paste and the second
output here is an 8.9
negative 1.81 0.2
and then down here we get a 1.41
zero 1.051 zero two six okay
um also we can kind of clean up here i
just realized we still have
math and math.e we don't need that
anymore because
uh this handles it for us so
how do we convert to batch so for
exponentiating
it turns out we don't actually need to
do anything because
these numpy functions here work by
default
at the individual value level
so if we print x
values i thought i did i thought i auto
completed that i guess i didn't
there we have our values it's actually
already done for us
and it's correct so the next question is
okay how do we do this step
so x values we don't need to change
anything there
for a batch but for some we do
so to illustrate sum rather than doing
the sum of the exponential values it's
kind of hard to visually add these up
um we're going to do the sum
of let's do this
i'm just going to comment these out uh
we are going to
let's just print uh np.some
layer outputs now remember what do we
want to do here
we actually want to iterate over here
over this
2d matrix we want to iterate over this
and do this
the sum this sum this sum
and this sum but by default i already
told you it's going to do
as individual values so by default what
we get
is a single scalar value
that's not what we wanted we really want
three values
for sure we want three values so how do
we get those three values
so the first order of business is to
pass the axes
parameter here so we're gonna say axes
and
the axes by default is actually none and
that gives us the same value that we saw
before
axis zero to put it extremely simply on
a 2d matrix
it's going to be the sum of columns so
we're going to run this again and as you
can see 15.11
is this column and then 0.451 is this
column and 2.611 is
is this last column
unfortunately that's not what we want we
actually want the sum
of the rows put simply so we can change
that to axes one
and sure enough what we get is what we
hoped for
which is the sum here here and here
now we still have a slight problem what
we're what are we trying to do
with this sum well it turns out we're
trying to take these exponential values
which has this shape it's it is a matrix
and we're attempting to divide it um by
what we do the sum operation with
and we don't actually want to
just willy-nilly divide it it's really
important that things line up so it's
for the same reason that we want to make
sure values are lining up
um when we do the dot product and when
we're doing like a matrix product right
so even though np dot dot it is a dot
product with vectors but it's also doing
a matrix product for us
we need those values to line up so we do
a transpose
right for that same reason we need the
right values to line up here
right now if we did this it's gonna
um it's not going to actually be
dividing what we want
um exponentials to be divided by right
uh so so so what we want to do is we
need to shape this correctly
and we could reshape this uh but we can
also
just simply use keep dims so keep
uh is it keep dims yeah all one word and
then true
run that and now it is a matrix of the
exact same
um i hate to say shape but
it it's the same um orientation it's the
same dimensions
okay uh so so it's just a sum so now it
is literally
this right here it's just the sum of
these values the sum of these values and
then the sum of these values
so with that what we can do is we can
say the
norm values is exponential values
divided by the sum
of exponential values at axes one
and then keep dims equals true
we get rid of this row here and
now we have
print norm values
we run that and now we have our actual
normalized values
so uh from this point um
we really have one more thing and i
think we'll cover it here
is um
one problem that we have up to this
point is with
with specifically exponential values
um so there's there's one thing that we
want to change with this exponential
values before we convert this to
our actual class object so um
so with that let us go ahead and talk
about
what we're going to do with exponential
values one slight issue with
exponentiation is the explosion of
values as the input to
the exponential function grows
it doesn't take much to get massive
numbers and
even worse it doesn't take too long to
reach an
overflow
so one way to combat this overflow is to
take
all the values in this output layer
prior to exponentiation
and subtract the largest value in that
layer
from all of the values in that layer and
what this causes
is the now the largest value will be a
zero and everything else
is going to be less than zero now
because the largest value prior to
exponentiation
is actually a zero our range of
possibilities
becomes somewhere between
zero and one after exponentiation
because the exponentiation of
zero equals one so this means our range
of values can only be between zero and
one
thus no more worrying about overflowing
so the final concern that you might have
is what sort of impact does subtracting
the max value
from everything have on the actual
output of the softmax activation
function
so all other things being equal and
assuming that we don't have some sort of
overflow error if we have two two
two output layers and one we don't
subtract the max from and one we do
after we do our exponentiation and our
normalization the
actual output is identically the same
the only thing we've done is protected
ourselves
from an actual overflow error all right
so with the
subtraction of the max value in mind
we are going to now go to the code that
we left off on
with uh part five and we're going to add
our softmax activation class and then
we're going to
implement it here as well as change
things here
i've kind of used different variable
names and stuff like that
so i'm going to attempt to convert this
to be exactly what we have in the book
as well
and so and by doing that we'll also be
able to finally test the softmax
activation function
so uh these are the changes that we want
to make so first off
we're going to be redefining this data
so i'm actually going to delete
these then
we'll just add this underneath the relu
activation function and we're going to
say class
um activation activation underscore
softmax and then we're going to define
the
forward method again self
inputs and now we're just going to
implement the code that we've talked
about and covered already up to this
point except for the max thing but i'm
going to show you that
in a moment so the exponential
underscore
values is going to be equal to np dot x
of inputs and then we want to minus the
np.max
and immediately alarm bells should be
sort of going off and
that is if we run np.max and we for
example we're going to say mp.max
inputs and also while we're here
what is inputs so up to this point
inputs
in this case because we're using the
softmax activation function for
the activation function of an output
layer inputs are actually the
outputs so far of our model right
and so again we've got these outputs and
those
outputs are going to be
in batch form so there will be a batch
of these outputs so if we just said
np.max of inputs which would be an
np.max
of a batch of outputs up to this point
it's going to be the highest value of
all of those values
now you'd probably get away with it
um i
i think it would probably work but it
would be a mistake it would work but not
very
not as well as it should so instead what
um what you want to say is mp.max inputs
of
and immediately you should already know
where we're headed it's going to be of
axes
1 and then again keep dims will be true
so we're going to take inputs which is
going to be this batch of inputs
and again we want to subtract the max
along
of axes one and then we want to keep
that dimension
right of of that that um
array so once we've done that
uh we now have our exponential values of
a batch
and we are subtracting the max along the
way
again so we don't we just don't hit an
overflow value the actual outputs will
be exactly the same um after we
normalize and all that so we're not
really losing anything by doing this
we're just preventing an overflow
so exponential values is done now we're
going to say
probabilities is going to be equal to
x values divided by
np dot sum of the exponential values
of axes one axis one keep dimms
is going to be true and again we've
already actually this we've already
covered but again we're trying to sum
each of the rows
and we want to keep the dimension so
finally
we're going to define our self.output
and that is going to be
the probabilities okay
so that's our softmax activation
function and now what i want to make
sure i do is i use the exact same
layer values and so on so uh we already
got rid of the code up above
i think
i think what i'll do i think we'll just
code it
um from scratch here so here is our
framework up to this point well first
thing we're going to do is define our
data so x
y is going to be equal to spiral data
and then we're going to say samples
how many samples do we want to have
we're going to say 100 per class
and we're going to say classes we're
going to have three separate classes
now i guess pep 8 now what we're going
to do is we're going to say dense
1 is equal to layer dense
and the shape here is going to be 2
and then 3 so we only have two input
features again
spiral data is just x y data so it's
just coordinates so
the input here is going to be x y that's
2. so the input must be 2.
now the output could be anything you
want you could say 90 if you wanted
but we're going to say 3 because we're
going to follow we're going to say 3
because we're going to follow the book
now um
after we've got dense one we're gonna
we're gonna define also
activation one and that will be a
activation value
and then we're gonna define dense 2 is
going to be another
layer dense it the input because the
output of the previous layer was a 3
the input must be 3. now the output
could be anything we want but we're
going to treat this like it's an output
layer so how many neurons should this
output layer have well we have three
classes
so we're gonna say three so dense two is
defined
and then we're gonna say activation
activation
two is going to be an activation
softmax and then now we're going to
begin passing data actually through here
so we're going to say dense 1
dense 1 dot forward and we're going to
forward
our actual input data here then we need
to activate it so
activation 1 dot forward
dense one dot output
then we're going to pass that through
dense two so we're gonna say
dense two dot forward
activation one dot output
and then activation two dot
forward the output from dense two
and at this point because we do the
forward we now have the output which is
going to be probabilities
so for example we can print activation
two dot
output and let's just do the there
should be 300 of them
so we're going to just do the first five
let's go ahead and run that and what we
get
is again this is this is a batch
okay so we passed all of them at the
same time in this case
so we theory had a batch of 300.
now each of these is unique is a like so
this is a sample
so this had an input of two values and
this is each neuron value of
of those two values and it just
continues to repeat and then this is
just the first five
now it should be no surprise everything
was initialized randomly
so it turns out that
the distribution of predictions is
indeed random
it's a perfect you know not a perfect
but very close to a perfect one-third
prediction for everything this is
totally normal
when you randomly initialize a model
that's kind of what you expect
so now what we need to do is actually
train this model because like for
example
let's see if any of these are obviously
bigger than the others
three three three five so in this case
right if we did an r max on this right
here
um this class you know of index
2 is the largest
unless i'm missing something but anyways
it is the largest it looks like
so um so b that would be the prediction
and maybe that would be accurate maybe
that would be correct but instead what
we want to really do
is we don't want to know just which
what's right and wrong we want to know
how right and how wrong and to calculate
that we use a
loss function and that is the topic of
the
next video so if you've got any
questions comments concerns whatever
uh up to this point we kind of covered a
lot but i think the softmax activation
function is
relatively simplistic to pick up but if
you have questions comments concerns
whatever
feel free to leave those below again the
physical versions of the books are done
uh as are obviously the ebook and all
that's ready to be downloaded
and consumed so if you want to follow
something to follow along with the
videos or you want to kind of refresh or
refresh from the videos or read before
the video watch video that kind of stuff
definitely check that out at nnfs.io
otherwise i will see you guys in another
video
you